what would it take for you and the other
guys from sob to ever do like a reunion
project
or is that has there been so much [ __ ]
said to where it's like no coming back
from at this point
i don't think that [ __ ] happened again
yeah i don't know about that one i mean
if that [ __ ] happened [ __ ] we we must
be dead
wow
that's what it is or somebody else put
that [ __ ] without everybody permission
type [ __ ] like you family
what what about you and slimy would you
guys do like an offshoot of like
since you're still tight with him like
we just dropped the tape
cause we
dropped the take on still ganging like a
couple months ago i think in september
was that uh received well from like the
og fans
you said it was a receiver yeah like did
like like like did that because you know
i feel like a lot of a lot of you guys
fans were so [ __ ] crazy and diehard
yeah i was [ __ ] with that [ __ ] but a
lot of [ __ ] you know how they
want they want the whole group but like
you feel me that's only the beginning
like you can
worry about it like we got
we got [ __ ] on the way like it should
only get better and better
hey there it is man shout out to vallejo
vallejo's finest in the building um so
look november 12th the album is out
november 12th house
yes sir